rather than Thomas Bryant  cannot give the Lakers the lead  Bullock called for the foul his fifth as  Westbrook hits him deck now he pops up  and now some words being exchanged  all the assistant coaches do a good job  keeping the players  on the bench  and so he has meta right away on the  foul call twirled the finger to indicate  he was going to go look at this  which would indicate he's thinking there  was maybe something flagrant here watch  him right here he's  he's indicating he's going to look at  this as a possible flagrant foul lower  the shoulder  [Applause]  clearly  initiating a little extra contact here  on donchic  not the time you want to want to be  picking up a flagrant and give him  the ball back after shooting free throws  [Music]  50 of the game tonight